it's daddy hey guys this is derek with
new media rockstars ringing on the son
of four green room at playlist live
we're going to talk to some of the best
youtubers in the world check it out
we're wassabi productions was the first
video that made you want to start making
your own youtube videos you remember
that one video with the Backstreet Boys
guy your inspiration was two asian guys
singing backstreet boys yes what's a
viral video you wish would go away I
don't like the Fox yeah what has a foxy
I don't know can we get you the sign
just what's up guys Philip walk here we
are at the playlist live Orlando this is
the new media rock stars and we have a
new media talks to alex g how are you i
am so great thanks for having me yeah so
happy you are also here booya in the
houses in all the houses that's right
all of them apartments condominiums are
you also performing live here I already
did it the full screen sweet it went
really well I played some new originals
oh it looks so bad why does it playlist
don't end up your head out and not me
know
we're in the green room right now but
it's got green spoiler alert boileau
it's not green it was like the first
video you watched on YouTube the first
video I watched on YouTube was
definitely mine because I posted videos
for probably like a month or two before
I realized other people were posting
videos seeing who's the last person
young subscribed for me hahaha it's one
of those channels that posts like 10 of
videos a day so it wasn't like I didn't
like the videos it was just there were
way too many in my feed who is your
favorite youtuber the hasn't been seen
yet that's a really good question I've
been watching this kid who's a young boy
who I love his name is Ben Pierce and I
hope to meet him he made a really funny
video it's been a great day here
playlist live read and check out these
other videos right here and right here
also don't forget subscribe to new media
rockstars be cool guys be cool